è iniziato tutto qua dentro incredibile
Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono Favij oggi
Ciao sono lucaggio dei pacchi No l'ho
dovuto dire come lo dice una volta che
molti di voi non lo sapranno ma io ai
tempi facevo questa cosa chiamata
scartaggio dei pacchi Dove scartavo
appunto i pacchi che i fan mi inviavano
a casa questa cosa in realtà la sanno
tutti però siccome mi sono arrivati
negli anni milioni di pacchi alla fine
nel tempo non sono mai riuscito a
scartarli tutti Allora ho detto perché
non fare uno scartaggio dei pacchi
definitivo e soprattutto tornare a
Torino perché erano tutti pacchi che
ricevevo quando facevo i video nella mia
cameretta oggi siamo qua per provare ad
aprirle vedere che cosa c'è dentro
perché ormai è roba di 10 anni fa Magari
ci sono carte dei Pokémon che adesso
vogliono milioni di euro Speriamo
speriamo Allora qua vedo già roba
interessantissima eh abbiamo una molla
abbiamo un Pikachu giapponese che balla
un francobollo della Madonna Ah no non
voglio dire
una madonna sul francobollo Tanto siamo
in tema natalizio in tutto questo
infatti Loro anni fa lo sapevano mi
hanno inviato un Babbo Natale anche la
parte Attenzione ragazzi oh Emanuele e
Anna grazie Questa è una fan art dello
Slenderman Iscriviti io ti squarto il
cadavere comunque insegnavo delle cose
che non erano proprio Ecco Siamo tutti
pazzi tutti pazzi perché Seguimi anche
Favij quando erano 0 anni bene abbiamo
questo bellissimo scherzo ma questo è
bellissima ragazzi sembra Questa è
proprio a tema natale Questa è la
scatola più natalizia che c'è qua dentro
Forse questo regalo È pazzesco Perché
sembra una roba uscita dal Codice da
Vinci guarda ci sono tipo le scritte sul
Pack assurdo Ho preso questo Faro quando
sono andato a Santa Maria di Leuca
Perché tu per me sei come un faro
Che bellina
io abbaglio Grazie Rebecca ma è
bellissimo ragazzi è bellissimo È un
faro di Santa Maria di Leuca perché io
sono un faro Infatti guarda lo so fare
Tienilo fermo così uguale Grazie Rebecca
sono un faro e tu sei la mia luce
mettiamo del Romanticismo
il nome della macchina di Ciccio Ciccio
ha dato un nome alla sua macchina sì tu
hai dato la tua macchina
Ciao Lorenzo sono Rebecca tutto Rebecca
si chiamano Spero che il pacco ti sia
piaciuto
No non fare battute Mi piacerebbe avere
una tua foto autografata e me la puoi
mandare a Rebecca Bravo Rebecca 10 anni
questo pacco ha 10 anni quindi Rebecca
20 anni non ci credo Quindi adesso
andiamo una foto fotografata a Rebecca
che mi ha disegnato Cat Mario gliela
mando Voglio vedere che succede dai
andiamo andiamo
veramente curioso di vedere la faccia di
queste persone Adesso avrai la mia foto
Adesso magari non te ne frega più una
sega ma te la mando perché tu l'hai
chiesto e c'è un regalo perché è Natale
e quindi questa è la seconda volta in
questo video eh due regali di Natale a
Natale e abbiamo una t-shirt Life is
better with a Bird Cioè in italiano vuol
dire che la vita è migliore con la barba
[ __ ] Rebecca No scherzo e becca lo
sapeva e mi ha preso per il culo anche a
distanza di 10 anni grazie perché un
bacio e usa sta forza
Bravo
Nutella scaduta nel 2014 c'è una scritta
Chissà cosa sarà fatta abbino Nicola
salutone da Federico e Noemi grazie per
Noemi
pronto no
carte Pokémon del 2014 signori
Federica Federico Guarda queste carte
qua e dimmi quanto valgono per favore
Grazie schifino nei commenti Ti voglio
bene lo sapevo che avrei risolto carte
Pokémon poi non le chiedevo per la
doccia incredibile
però ce l'ho io Grazie ragazzi grazie
grazie delle carte Pokémon allora questo
è un po' più recente del 2017 per Favij
da Chiara dei fazzoletti grazie Qui c'è
dentro questo pacco c'era qui c'era
c'era questo Scusate c'era il profumo
alla fragranza di Favij vogliamo provare
il profumo alla fragranza lo provo Tu sì
sì sì certo vieni qua a provare il
profumo alla fragranza di Favij
che sa di morte
bro molto probabilmente leggerai questa
lettera quando avrai 23 anni e non 22 ne
ho 27 Grazie Patù calamite
personalizzate la mia faccia Sì qua c'è
il tuo loghino vecchio della TV un pezzo
di pizza Oh zio
che figo un cappello con Meo mi hai
fatto benissimo
perché è impolverato quindi lo testa Lui
poi lo testa lo so Eh Che succede Eh
guarda guarda un cappellino
perché ho paura sia impolverato Mamma
mia che esagerato che sei esagerato così
belli pensa a fare questi ci fai vedere
i videotrap ci fate Vabbè una lettera
lunghissima e super tenera Mamma mia che
questa ragazza che si è innamorata di 19
anni 10 anni fa tutto questo non è vero
sanno Ah no io qua vent'anni avevo
capito Qua c'è scritto
ragazzi di vent'anni dare una forza
spropositata una ragazza di 18 anni sono
pure vicini di età sarà il tuo vero
amore Chiara
di Pordenone sarai il vero amore di
Lorenzo sicuramente 7 anni fa Sì scusa
se l'ho fatto provare prima Giampiero e
che avevo paura fosse impolverato ma un
vero cuore che batte non si in polvere
mai
Comunque
ragazzi l'ultimo pacco di Today Oh
possiamo concludere in bellezza Una
orsacchiottino carino con una pezza col
cuore qua
Grazie ragazzi che che che che che vi
posso dire io È assurdo che dopo tutto
questo tempo io mi emoziona ancora così
tanto perché comunque già i tempi quando
ricevo dei pacchi mi faceva strano mi
faceva strano che qualcosa di digitale
si convertisse in fisico Quindi tutti
quei numeri in realtà erano persone che
mi volevano bene però mi vogliono ancora
bene perché mi inviavano appunto regali
cose del genere No realizzare questa
cosa era strano ai tempi mi ricordo che
la prima i pacchi Insomma quindi questa
cosa è tangibile poi me ne sono accorto
negli anni perché comunque mi fermate
tutti in giro ancora adesso scartando
questi pacchi mi fa ancora questo
effetto mi fa mmm mmm mi mi mi rendo
sempre conto di quanto le persone mi
vogliono bene E questa cosa mi rende
veramente felice mi sa fa sentire un
calore che non vi so spiegare Cioè mi
sento coccolato e Questa è una bella
cosa Quindi grazie Veramente Grazie
mille ragazzi Spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto questo era uno scartaggio di
pacchi magari in futuro lo faremo di
nuovo nel senso che comunque posso
riaprire
qualche Special le cose del genere così
mi inviate qualcosa anche adesso che
avete tutti una famiglia con dei figli
ci vediamo ragazzi come sempre un
prossimo episodio iscrivetevi al canale
lasciate un bel mi piace un commento qua
sotto e noi come sempre ci vediamo ad un
prossimo video che bello dirlo in questa
stanza qua però il telecomando ce l'ho a
Milano quindi con la salviettina bella
ragazzi